It's BOSHY time.
Felix: It's Boshy time. Hell yea everybody, This is the moment you've all been waiting for
Oh PewDiePie's playing I Wanna Be the Guy but I Wanna Be the Boshy is way harder
Oh Pewdiepie didn't even finish I Wanna Be the Guy- %^$%^$^%
I lost the save file, and I can't be fucked okay, but let's play I wanna be Boshy
Oh, it's so hard. Oh, it's so hard
Ayeee *stfu*
All right, here's the tutorial like I haven't figured that out.
[Kirby music playin']
What the-
[Kirby music continuing]
Shut- I know how to play a game.
Oh no. Oh no, I can't do the tutorial... Oh no.
[Moaning]
Oh, this is bad.
Ohhh look at that, easy. Shooting. Use the X-Key to shoot a bullet wi- WHAT?
What the
*[Fuck yeah... Fuck yeah] in the background*
Save jump it can be done by.... Oh shoot a save point.
Stfu
[Here we go] It's Boshy time
It's- It's- It- It's Bo- It's B-
It's Bosh- It's Boshy time...
It's Bo- It's Bo- It's Bosh- It's Bo-
*Fuck yeah*
It's Boshy time!
Hey, I did it! God damn, I'm a genius. I see I don't need those... Go away from me
Okay, here we go everybody. Hey good. OOohheehhhh
Ohh great... Noooo I go back here. Are you kidding me?
Alright alright so that wasn't actually a save. That's so annoying... Oh my god
Where do I go? Oh my god?
Okay... Alright
What if I go over it... Oh, okay?
Are you kidding me
Alright you can't- you can't do anything. Where do I go? Where do I go? Oh my god!
So annoying
HAAAA
HAAAAAA
Stop being so annoying. Alright, don't jump
I'm just gonna- Okay, okay, where am I?
What
Okay all right. Where am I... What killed me here last time. I have no idea
Okay, I-
Oh God are you kidding me? That looks super difficult! I don't even see how!
Great... Good job [x2] Oh my god. Of course. Why don't I just shoot it there?
Did the save just shoot me back?
Lemme try this.... HA
What are you gonna do now huh? whatchu gon do now HUH?
umm..
Why did I do this... Oh the game is- the game is slowing down
Ahhh... Game, can you- You can stop... You can stop now game? Oh God? Oh? Oh, it's-
not Boshy time
I don't want boshy time... I don't want it. I don't want it anymore. Wait, F3 changes my character?
[intense music]
Oh look at dat!
[More intense music]
Hey look at...
What!? I can play as Pedobear, that's like my favorite character
What the hell I'm way too slow... Who even is Boshy, and why is he so mean
Come on. This is easy
this bit is easy bit
I forgot that I needed to go to the place- you ******* **** You frickin Frick, I mean. Sorry Youtube
Com'on Pedobear you can totally do it
This is ez
This is super-
EZ
It's fine [x2]
It's fine... All right don't worry about me
Worry about yourself, HUH, have you ever worried about yourself before, HUH maybe that's why you're a slob sitting at home...
Watching fucking YouTube videos
You loser
I'm a winner, OK? I'm a winner look at this
[Swearing in Swedish]: But you fucking cunt's fucking cunt-cake (no, not a typo lol)
I think... I think this game might be a little difficult. I don't know. I don't know what- wada wada wanted to say about
The game... It might be- It might-
I can't even **** suck my own **** I can't even do the first thing
I can't even d-do the first thing
90 times??
No, go up on it mannn
It sucka **** time
Com'on Boshy you can do it mann... I believe in you
Look at the- look at these ma-
This is great. This is great. This is great. This is great. This is great. This is just what I want
This is what I wanted and you wanted a challenge
It's just not even that difficult
You're on the first jump Poodz... You're on the first
God Damn... Ju- fine
What the hell were you thinking? Come on, come on
Focus
You got this, come on [x3]
Come on. Come on.
[Swedish]: come on, you fucking-
[whisper] Are you retarded [x3]
[mumbling] I ain't givin' up
I really should give up- I realy shou- I- I should give up... Neva. Neva quit. I ain't a *Kweder*
Imma Quada
I'm a Quack
I'm a *hoarse sound*
I'm a Kezzo
I'm a Kess-
I'm a Kettzz- Are you ffff-
How am I getting worse?!
Com'on man
Felix... Seriously, you just have to focus on yourself
Stop doin' the stupid voices and focus for once
Good job, you- [laughter]
[Swedish]: it was really close that time!
[Swedish]: it was super close, like!
[Swedish]: You laugh?
[Swedish]: Ey, man? Ey man, you want some c*ck?
Huh? Huh!?
[Swedish]: Answer then! You'll get-!
[Swedish]: Yes but of course... [x2]:
[Swedish]: (?) -if you outsmart them you'll get some cock, huh? Huh?
[Swedish]: Do you want a little something in your ass, or? Huh? You-
Jävlar!
Damnit!
I can do it. I know I can. I just need to do it once and then I know I can do, okay. That's how it works
Get up on it!!!!
Am I even recording? Where did it go?
[Swedish]: Come ooonnnn!
Okay, go here, jump down there, wait-
This is where evolution has taken us... God damn it, come on
I can't even do the first jump. I can't do the first jump. I just can't- I can't do it. I just can't do it
I just cannot-
DO IT
COM'ON COM'ON... Are you KIDDING me?
How are you this bad?! Be quiet, be quiet, all right?
I don't need you talking to me like that, come on, give me some encouragement... Damn it
Yeah, you can do it! Yes, I can do it, look at me go
Easy [x2]
Easy... Look at that shit, look at it
And now he does th-
[Sobbing]
AGAINNNNNN
[Panting]
[Crazy laugher]
[plus demon laughter]
[Heavy breathing]
[Typing]
[click]
"I am dead inside"